[Musique]
blanc louis a voté c'était dimanche 28
septembre à la mairie de levallois
cette dame comme vous comme nous a fait
son devoir de citoyenne
[Musique]
la notion du devoir est une chose
qu'elle connaît depuis l'otan pense elle
est né en 1854
mais oui c'est la doyenne des français
blasé elle ne l'est pas cependant son g
koné sous le règne de napoléon le
troisième elle a vu 18 président de la
république
elle attire et l'aiguillât la lumière de
la lampe à pétrole du gaz de
l'électricité
elle a connu trois guerres deux
insurrections 71 et 44 elle a vu
construire la tour eiffel le sacré coeur
le trocadéro qu'elle a même vu démolir
par la suite et le baron haussmann a
tracé ses célèbres avenues pour ses 16
ans les expositions et les comptes plus
celle de bruxelles dernier en date ua
plus mais la galerie des machines
c'était tout de même autre chose
les techniques modernes n'ont pas de
secret pour elle c'est dans la fumée
d'une cigarette que les niveaux mieux
les ombres du pass elle a tellement
connu de choses en 105 ans en trente
huit mille trois cent cinquante et un
jour si vous préférez un ebe sextile
pour prise ou mieux en 920 1414 heures
réalité de la vie contemporaine le
téléphone n'a ses exigences
[Musique]
seize aussi de la caméra de philippe
real car tout cela n'était en quelque
sorte qu'un jeu un jeu de très grandes
personnes régler pour les impératifs de
la télévision afin de vous mieux
présenter cette charmante vieille dame
qui après avoir connu lempire la
troisième et la quatrième république
lève joyeusement sa coupe de champagne
en pensant à la 5e
[Musique]